Schlechte nachrichten während das ozon noch. Immer kleiner wird wird die ozonschicht immer dünner das sind ziemliche
hiobsbotschaften war es also ein irrglaube dass beim
Ozon alles besser wird geht der erde doch der schutz vor der gefährlichen uv strahlung flöten klicks. Um,
science-fiction herzlich willkommen heute übrigens von der ju dem ewz sommerfestival aus berlin
Thema nummer 1 sehen den späten 80er
jahren
Das ozonloch mit hilfe des montreal protokolls gelang es der internationalen umweltpolitik
Die so dringende kehrtwende einzuleiten. Und zwar wurde die herstellung von fckw also den langlebigen flur
kohlenwasserstoffen beschränkt vorher massiv
Eingesetzt als kältemittel in kühlschränken und als treibgas für sprühdosen
und sie zerstören das ozon in den hohen schichten der erdatmosphäre
Massiv, dabei ist die ozonschicht extrem wichtig für alle lebewesen auf der erde nämlich als schutzschild. Gegen die
lebensbedrohliche
Uv-b-strahlung erstmals gibt es eine gute nachricht seit dem montrealer abkommen ist der verbrauch
und auch die produktion der schädlichen flow kohlenwasserstoffe fckw
Um rund 90 prozent. Zurückgegangen kammer doch eine. Schnelle erholung der ozonschicht sei dennoch nicht zu erwarten
Sagt die weltorganisation für meteorologie. Wmo
denn die schädlichen chemikalien
Bauen, sich extrem langsam ab eine zahl macht allerdings. Hoffnung, denn der
ozongehalt der atmosphäre hat sich seit dem jahr 2000 stabilisiert
So studien welche zahlen sind nun aussagekräftig. Und wie steht es wirklich
Um das ozonloch, erst kürzlich ist dazu eine studie heraus gekommen an denen wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen aus der schweiz
und zwar das physikalisch mythologischen auf sat 1 in davos
beteiligt waren und die ergebnisse sind
Besorgniserregend denn sie zeigen dass das. Ozonloch zwar
immer kleiner wird doch die ozonschicht über den tropen und den mittleren breiten
Dünnt weiter aus das fazit der forscher und forscherinnen ist alarmierend. Denn es zeigt dass die ozonschicht
Noch nie, so dünn gewesen ist wie derzeit aber schauen wir doch mal detailliert auf die einzelnen ergebnisse gut sieht es bezüglich des
Ozon gehaltes in der oberen stratosphäre aus nämlich in einer. Höhe von
32 bis 48 kilometern zudem zeigt sich auch dass sich das ozonloch
Über der antarktis erholt hat seitdem das montrealer abkommen geschlossen wurde schlechte nachrichten dagegen aus den unteren
Atmosphärenschichten, und zwar von der meereshöhe bis zu durchschnittlich zwölf kilometern die
Aktuellen ergebnisse legen nahe dass dort seit 1987 ozon verloren geht. Um zwar kontinuierlich
Und unaufhaltsam eine entwicklung die das forschungsteam so nicht erwartet hat denn
Genau, auf die erholung dieser unteren schicht also von null bis zwölf kilometern da kommt es darauf an und macht den erfolg in den
oberen schichten in gewisser weise wieder zunichte
Dennoch passen diese horror ergebnisse nicht zur vorherigen studien, und schätzungen nach denen, sich das
ozonloch erholt ja sogar schließen soll doch schaut, man
Genauer hin sieht man auch den grund dafür in vorherigen forschung hat man sich vor allem das sogenannte total
Ozon angeschaut damit ist diejenige. Ozon menge. Gemeint. Die von der erdoberfläche bis zur
obersten grenze der stratosphäre reicht hier wird der verlust durch das wachstum
Kompensiert ja und forschungsteams weltweit versuchen schon seit längerer zeit die atmosphäre. Und ihre mechanismen
Zu verstehen doch hierbei spielen einfach, zu viele faktoren eine rolle, beispielsweise der luftaustausch. Zwischen den unterschiedlichen
Atmosphärenschichten. Genauso wichtig aber ist es die ursachen. Zu finden die hinter dem enorm ozonabbau steckt möglicherweise
liegt es an den sogenannten very short lift substances vsl es also
Kurzlebigen halogen verbindung die aus industriellen prozessen stammt denn
auch sie gelangen in die stratosphäre und schädigen dort die
Ozonschicht das hatte eine studie eines münchner forschungsteams gezeigt aber
Auch der klimawandel hat wohl, auswirkungen auf das ozon denn die erderwärmung könnte
zu einer veränderten luftverteilung in der stratosphäre, führen
Und auch die schädlichen fckw sind noch längst nicht geschichte alte kühlgeräte
werden, noch längst nicht auf der ganzen welt
Ordnungsgemäß recycelt das fckw wird dort einfach nicht. Eingesammelt das forschungsteam der. Aktuellen studie allerdings. Äußerte die vermutung dass irgendwo
Heimlich noch größere mengen an fckw produziert werden durch die analyse verschiedener messmethoden schließen sie
darauf dass die gestiegenen emissionen in südostasien
Lokalisiert werden können doch das ist nur eine vage vermutung. Und keinesfalls bewiesen am ende
Jedenfalls hat die. Ausdünnung des ozons fatale folgen für uns. Alle denn es gibt immer weniger
Ozon das uns vor der uv-strahlung schützen kann
So steigt das hautkrebsrisiko bei menschen industrie politik und wissenschaft sind also in sachen ozon. Noch mindestens
Genauso gefragt und gefordert nach lösungen zu suchen wie eh, und je ja und wenn ihr keine videos dazu
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
Dann, umgeht er die kaputte a box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir. Noch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video. Und zwar täglich und
Garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal kriegs
um
social media abonnieren das gibt geht hier
Da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt also einfach hier draufklicken aber nicht die
Genau, glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Klimawandel weltweites wetterchaos hat begonnen bis. Dann
bleibt